of introduction about the Institute we
are collaborative Research Institute for
theoretical computer science as well as
its connections to all other areas of
Sciences engineering Humanities and
whatnot and we run a pretty packed
schedule we have typically two programs
each semester and also a few years ago
we started summer programs which is you
know is one of them and each program has
you know between you know close to 50 to
70 long-term visitors both Junior and
senior who come here for workshops
collaborations and and so on and this
semester uh the summer term we have many
programs of which uh The computational
Innovation and data driven biology is
one of those and uh special thanks to
the correct foundation for its support
of this program and uh welcome to the
first Workshop in this program from
algorithms to Discovery in genome scale
biology and Medicine
so first I want to um thank on behalf of
the Simon's Institute the organizers
Stephen Brenner Ron Shamir Yoon song and
Olga troyanskaya for arranging an
excellent set of speakers for this week
and I'll hand over to the organizers for
introduction to the workshop itself so
here I'm just here to welcome you and
give some logistical information
so
um just some logistical information
snacks and drinks and coffee Etc will
all be outside and for lunches you're on
your own and please enjoy your food and
coffee outside we do not allow any um
food or coffee in the drinks in the
auditorium water is is from your water
bottles are okay of course and the
policy right now is uh masks are
optional but we strongly recommend that
when indoors you know you mask up if you
can
um and there are lockers just outside
where if you you know if you want to
store your backpacks during the day you
can and they're very easy to use if you
want to use Wi-Fi you do ROM works you
can also sign up for Cal visitor tends
to be a little more flaky but bedroom
works from your home institution that's
best
and I was just told we are not using a
hybrid format so this will be an all
live uh you know good old style Workshop
so good luck with that and that's it and
finally I just want to thank uh kelani
Penland who's standing outside there uh
our events coordinator for all our work
on the local arrangements to make this
event run smoothly
um and if you have any questions uh you
know she'll be around feel free to find
her and ask her okay with that uh
welcome again and let me turn it over to
the organizers
hello uh I'm Ron Samir from Tel Aviv
University and together with Stephen
Brenner from UC Berkeley we are the copy
eye of the correct Berkeley Tel Aviv
initiative in computational biology and
bioinformatics so this is an ongoing
initiative that is in its fourth year by
now and it Fosters collaborations
between Tel Aviv and Berkeley in the
field of computational biology and it's
funded by the correct Foundation
uh
finally after three tries we are having
this summer program
uh it was planned for uh 2020 and again
for 2021 and finally we could
uh make it happen now so we are going to
have two conferences this is the first
one and there are also about
between two and three dozen students and
pis who will be here for all or most of
their uh five weeks of the program for
interaction and collaboration so I think
there are the persistent uh
heads of the program for doing it again
and again until it actually happened and
the team at the Simons for uh all the
help and support Stephen probably
so I just wanted to welcome everyone
here to Berkeley it's great to have you
here as Ron said I remember back in 2018
planning in 2019 and in Tel Aviv
planning out details of this meeting and
then planning them again and again and
again I think it's perhaps appropriate
that within the last week we've had to
change our first Speaker twice for this
meeting but it's great to see all of you
here physically here now there's meeting
happening and none of and rodded really
did the greatest lifting here and making
this happen we're really grateful them
for doing this over and over and over
again I think that we have a great week
of science ahead and so I want to thank
them I want to thank all the speakers
all of you who've joined us and again
also we are really appreciative to the
court Foundation which has sponsored
this incredible program that's allowed
us to have the collaborations between
Berkeley until the university if anyone
has any more questions about that
program
um you can look at our website or ask me
or Ron any more questions so thank you
very much and welcome
with it
so hi uh I'm Odette from Tel Aviv
University and I think as a born in
Stephen mentioned it's
quite a miracle that everyone is here
uh not everyone actually my
co-organizer couldn't make it because of
these hard times but he might join us
tomorrow at least for the brainstorm
session online
uh so so let me start from the end I
really wish to thank all of you who made
the effort and managed to come here
despite everything despite Kobe despite
the airports despite whatever uh so I'm
really grateful for all of you
um
okay so
um this Workshop that we are starting
which is called from algorithms to
discover in genome scale biology and uh
oh in medicine uh
we'll include The Cutting Edge Toxin
genomics and systems biology which will
cover both algorithmic development as
well as a
biotechnological Innovations
and more specifically today we will hear
talks on Gene regulation highlighting
the importance of spatial omics
or special omic data
uh and then we will have the postal
session as well as the reception
tomorrow we will hear talks on Precision
medicine
and tomorrow we are also planning this
brainstorming session on the future of
the field and I really urge you anyone
who hasn't yet uh completed the
questionnaire that we shared with you uh
please uh input your feedback
on Thursday uh we will hear algorithmic
and technological development talks in
network biology
and finally on Friday we will focus on
the problem of predicting uh phenotypes
from genotypes and let me just wish all
of us uh success in in this meeting
thank you
[Music]
thank you
all right
I guess it's working
there we go
right uh huge pleasure to be here I
really want to thank uh brother and
nadav and for all the organizers for uh
bringing me here I've I've lived in the
Bay Area for 15 years and
been visiting Berkeley since 1992.
uh did a postdoc up the hill
I don't know which way that is Lawrence
Berkeley lab okay that way Ron is
pointing that way uh
uh and uh also did some experiments at
Lawrence Berkeley lab as a physicist
during my PhD
uh but then I switched to genomics for
my postdoc again at Lawrence Berkeley
lab but yeah uh and so know the space
very well know NADA very well sadly is
not here he and I did a postdoc together
at Lawrence Berkeley lab uh spent many
years and I've heard rather talk in
Berkeley I probably heard you talk also
Ron over there and maybe many of the
people here so it's kind of like coming
back home to be here
all right uh can we talking today about
uh spatialomics algorithm that we
developed recently and very excited
about and uh with this audience I'm
really looking forward to some feedback
I think this is the first time I'm
presenting it to a complete proper
computational biology audience so
excited about that
so evolution of genomics uh
hydropogenomics so we started with bulk
genomics I I presume most of you know is
just mashed up tissues and then you
count the molecules in those mashed up
tissues which is much easier because if
you take a lot of tissue and match it up
mash it up you got
millions and billions of molecules to
count and if you're measuring anything
is easier to measure large quantities
than to measure small quantities right
your measurements are just more accurate
more sensitive so that was the easy and
that's why people did bugs genomics not
because they wanted to do but genomics
it was the only choice they had
technologically single cell genomics was
not possible on a high throughput scale
but then of course in 2009 I think was
the first single cell rna-seq paper and
even before that I think most people
don't know there was some single cell
microarray gene expression papers also
so and that really changed the game now
the beauty of single cell analysis is
that you're no longer mashing up
we're no longer mashing up the the
tissue right into this uh homogeneous
mush
you're taking apart the tissue into its
component parts and looking at each part
individually and then you get a much
better idea of what what's happening in
that tissue right but obviously you know
this analogy you know there's one more
image here there's some empty space here
the this this is incomplete right
because you you want to know how these
things fit together
you really want to see this right you
want to see the component parts of the
tissue in their spatial environment in
their spatial architecture then you
really understand their function and
interactions and that's what was missing
even though single cell technology was
incredible and powerful and it's kind of
becoming the default for expression
profiling in tissues what you really
want is spatial genomics all the power
of single cell measure all the genes all
the expression chromatin everything
without destroying the tissue just keep
the cells where they are in the tissue
right that that's the dream and now
there's an explosion of spatialomics
Technologies lots of startups lots of
big companies getting into that space we
are collaborating with one of them for
the technology development and so not
surprisingly right so in 2020 nature
methods named spatialomics as the method
of the year and before that single cell
RNA seek twice one method of the year in
2013 and 2019.
so what is spatialomics
so you get data like this okay this is a
dented gyrus of the hippocampus I think
the mouse brain hippocampus uh each
little blob or dot each blob is a cell
and uh you can see here the different
colors I think either the cells are
colored by cell type or they're coloring
molecular markers of those individual
cell types right so here you can see
beautifully all the richness and cell
type diversity of a complex tissue and
its spatial architecture right this this
is what you want you want to be able to
measure all let's say 20 000 genes or
thirty thousand genes whatever measure
their expression in the spatially
resolved way it's not really possible
right now or it's possible in principle
but at low sensitivity and often at low
spatial resolution ultimately one
subcellular molecular resolution
single molecule resolution and you want
to be able to have 100 sensitivity
meaning detect every molecule that's
there in the tissue but we're getting
there we're on their way there right
so uh now obviously this is a powerful
data type right because you've got gene
expression and you've got spatial
location but the incredible thing is
that you know that's this this kind of
Technology maybe a precursor to this
came out in 2015 okay and my colleague
published this paper in 2015.
um but he did not use the spatial
information and the data when he was
analyzing the data
and down even in 2021 and I'm sure if we
look even in 2022 we'll find spatial
omics papers where you run algorithm
algorithms to say cluster this data
cluster the cells by gene expression and
you throw away this facial information
in the clustering which is crazy right
so obviously if you have information you
have to use it in your algorithm so why
is that right because the space is so
new it's very very new and people are
just working out how what's the best way
to incorporate spatial information in
your data and so we're taking a stab at
that too and we we're proposing one way
of doing that but we feel is
generalizable I'll show you how to use
that approach today for clustering but I
think it's a very general method it can
be used to solve a lot of spatulomics
algorithms problems not just clustering
right
so can we incorporate spatial
information cell type clusting of course
the answer is yes we can and people have
done it the question how best to do it
and does it work well
so uh I'll talk today about two specific
problems of incorporating spatulomics
they're both essentially clustering
problems okay one is clustering cell
types so and I'll describe what that
means in a minute meaning and then the
other is uh so meaning you're clustering
in some gene expression space okay each
dot is a cell and your space is gene
expression space in your clustering cell
by similarating the gene expression
space the other kind of clustering is
your clustering spatial locations
so your grouping spatial locations
together into a contiguous segment so
it's a segmentation problem you're
taking a 2D spatialomics image
segmenting it into connected spatial
domains in each connected domain is
presumably a biologically meaningful
unit let's say a cortical layer a layer
in your brain right
so these are two different clustering
problems one in expression space one in
saves physical or geometric space uh
what what are people doing here okay and
these are the two problems I'll address
today with this algorithm so this is
what the cell type clustering looks like
here I'm just showing non-spatial single
cell rnaic data for illustration there's
uh I think like 300 400 000 Dots here so
it looks like blobs but you have each
dot is a cell and this is some two
dimensional reduced dimensionality
projection of gene expression space okay
but it's a multi-dimensional thousands
of Dimensions unit expression space
cells that are new each other have the
same cell type you can know each other
in unit expression space that means
they're similar cells and so they have
the same cell type so those here the
cells are colored by cell type so these
are T cells these are NK cells monocytes
platelets Etc right and you can see here
the really distinct Islands our cell
types are very different within T cells
you have a Continuum of gene expression
so these are naive T cells these are
effective T cells in ifcd-479 an ifcd8 T
cells and so on so you have Continuum
within a major cell type and then you
have discrete Islands separating major
cell types so this is the cell type
clustering problem in gene expression
space okay now there's been not so many
algorithms but recently there's been
quite a few algorithms coming coming out
to do this spatially informed cell type
clustering okay uh for various kinds of
spatialomics data what are the
limitations still the relatively few
algorithms out there and they're not
widely adopted mostly the people who
publish the algorithm use it in their
paper but the broader field still uses
non-spatial clustering
uh perhaps one limitation that they
don't scale to large data sets Okay what
I mean a large data set 600 000 cells in
one single data set one single tissue
section so that's what uh Vision has
just released publicly online right
but all of these algorithms they were
tested on a few thousand cells and as
I'll show you they don't scale even to
100 000 cells most of them yes we have
600 000 cells today tomorrow we'll have
millions of cells next year we'll have
tens of millions of cells right so
scalability is a huge issue in genomics
single cell genomics and certainly in
spatial genomics then the existing
algorithms uh they use some combination
of deep learning deep neural networks
Auto encoders to transform your feature
space and Mark of random fields which is
how does your expression vary across
space right and they use either all or
both
uh but it's a question of how exactly do
you represent the spatial information
what is your cost function and so on
right uh and so it ends up having many
spurious clusters perhaps because of
deep learning doesn't is over fitted or
doesn't have enough data or because in
some cases the assumptions are the
marker random field method are not valid
what do I mean by that so
um let me quickly go back here okay so
the markup random field assume methods
they assume that neighboring cells have
the same cell type
but as you can see here there's many
regions in the brain where neighboring
cells even over here this is relatively
pure right you have different cell types
interspersed so that basic Assumption of
the Markov random field method is
violated by most complex tissues they
still work okay but you know if you want
Optimal Performance you have to make
assumption that perfectly fit the data
so
um then that cell type flashing and then
there's tissue domain segmentation
that's something like this okay these
are the layers of I think the human
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex these are
each color as one cortical layer this
manually annotated by experts okay
layers one to six and this is the white
matter
so you want to segment your space into
these contiguous biological structures
that's a tissue that domain segmentation
problem so this is slightly older so
there's more algorithms in the space
largely again I think the marker random
field uh Paradigm which actually is
technically valid for this kind of data
set because here in this data set you
know in one layer developing brain you
have mostly homogeneous cell types right
uh and that's why this data set has been
used a lot for benchmarking these
algorithms but it's in general it's that
assumption and not valid
uh so again I mentioned about the
validity of the assumptions and then
some of the deep learning methods they
may overfit the data okay so those are
the limitations how do we get around
them
and so this is our stab at it algorithm
is called building Aggregates with a
neighborhood kernel I'll tell you what
that means and spatial yardstick Banksy
there's a tradition in single cell to
name algorithms after artists so we
chose a slightly more subversive artist
but same still following tradition
uh I want to thank vipul and Nigel they
are the two co-first authors of this uh
and the algorithm developers and
benchmarkers primarily and then my
collaborators uh wikwan Lee and Kakao
Chen so Kakao is the first author of the
2015 more fish paper it was one of the
seminal papers in this field for
spatialomics technology and now now he's
in Singapore he's my colleague
so uh what does Banksy do just one very
simple transformation of the data and
then everything else is conventional
clustering okay what is that simple
transformation Banksy does feature
augmentation right it says what is a
logical way to incorporate spatial
information in the data it just
transform the data so this is your
initial data Matrix okay if I did not
have spatialomics data this is what my
data Matrix would look like each column
is a cell each row is a gene okay my
genes versus cells expression Matrix and
I want to Cluster myself you know so
each column here is the expression
Vector of one cell and I want to Cluster
the cell so that the cells near each
other have similar gene expression
vectors that's my normal single cell
clustering algorithm so what Banksy does
is it says let's use the same Machinery
of conventional single cell plus string
except let's do feature augmentation
let's double up the dimensionality of
the feature space so and what's the
biological logic here it says each cell
type has a characteristic transcriptome
and a characteristic neighborhood
meaning because it has a characteristic
distribution engine in in the tissue
right and that means it has a
character's neighborhood uh neighborhood
means nearby cells okay now this is the
biological assumption and uh it's
sensible what do we mean by neighborhood
how do we mathematically encode the
neighborhood so I've shown how we encode
the cell's own transcriptome it's just
the gene expression Vector of that cell
how do we uh encode the neighborhood so
the simplest thing you can do is just
take the cell so this is the cell's own
transcription take the cells immediate
neighbors you know K nearest Neighbors
in physical space in the tissue
average their transcriptomes average the
transcript terms of the K nearest
neighbors and append that to your
original feature vectors so now you have
a feature Vector that's twice as long
that's all you're doing right so now
you're encoding the cell by its own
transcriptome and its neighboring trans
Dome so you're incorporating spatial
information but you're not making this
session you're not assuming that the
nearby cells have the same transcript
you're allowing this Vector to be
different from this vector
that is a big that is much more
realistic
you're also not saying that cells of the
same type are necessarily know each
other cells can be highly intermingled
right so uh you can have let's let's say
you have this green cell type in this
green neighborhood here there may be a
green neighborhood here too and a green
neighborhood here that's okay right each
cell in a green neighborhood will have
the the green transcriptome
and its neighbors will also be green
right so then uh cells of the same type
will be clustered together not just in
this feature space but also in this
augmented feature space and then there's
a question of regularization or waiting
how much weight do you give to the sales
own transcript amount should be do you
give to the neighbor transcriptome so
then we just use a simple uh scale
factor that's square root of Lambda or
square root of 1 minus Lambda so what
this ends up being is that uh this
should be D Squared okay not D so this
is the euclidean distance in expression
space so uh d e is the euclidean
distance of the cell's own transcriptome
from another cells transcriptome and d s
is a euclidean distance of the cell's
neighbor transcriptome from the other
cells neighbor transcriptome okay and so
then you can see from these scale
factors that the actual D Squared in
this augmented space is just a linear
combination of the square distances in
the original space when Lambda is 0
this is one this is zero and then you
just have conventional single cell
clustering because you're only doing the
cell's own transcript from distance when
Lambda is 1 This this term is zero you
only have the neighbor transcriptome and
that is a domain segmentation mode of
Bank C so we use a Lambda of like 0.2 or
something typically for cell type
Plastering and a Lambda of close to one
for domain segmentation so the beauty of
this is you have one algorithm which is
one simple free parameter that you can
sensibly tune or intuitively tune and
that will give you either cell type
clustering algorithm or a domain
segmentation algorithm and after you do
this after you do this you don't need to
do anything else you can just take your
established single cell rnac clustering
software and just plug in you know
you'll always do some dimensionality
reduction just say let's say using PCA
and then you just plug your PCA
transformed version of this Matrix into
standard single cell clustering and then
it's highly scalable because existing
single cell rnac clustering algorithms
are highly scalable right so this
neighbor augmentation method uh strategy
it's biologically plausible and we've
used it for clustering you can use it
for any of the other you can use it for
I don't know trajectory analysis you can
use it for cell signaling analysis you
can use it for batch effect correction
really any any algorithm in a single
cell spatial omic space and we hope to
use it for all of those
places so uh how does it help okay now
let's say now the cell Zone expression
is a multi-dimensional vector the cells
neighborhood expressions and
multi-dimensional Vector let's just
simplify it by saying the sales X1
expression is a one-dimensional vector
and the sales neighborhood expression is
also one-dimensional Vector okay so then
each cell is a dot in now in this
two-dimensional space of own expression
neighborhood expression you can see here
we have these two cell types blue and
green
if you project them if you discard the y
axis we project them onto the x axis
which is own expression the blue cell
type in the green cell type they
separated by the somewhat intermingled
also so you have noise you don't these
are ambiguous cells you don't know what
the cell type is but because they have
different neighborhoods in this
two-dimensional space you can very
cleanly separate them right and this
this cartoon is really the intuition of
of Bank C
and you'll see I'll show you some
examples how where this exactly Works
where in your own expression space it's
fuzzy with neighborhood Expressions
really crisp
and so uh tagline is a cell is known by
the company it keeps which uh I thought
was very original but it turns out that
in natural language processing
people came up with this I I think
decades ago uh where they said a word is
known by the company it keeps so some of
you may know that natural language
processing words are encoded by the
frequency of their neighboring words in
a text
and that that tells you something uh
about the meaning of that word right and
so that's a very nice analogy which we
found out only after the after we
devised the algorithm that people in
natural language processing have been
using this strategy already for a long
time
and uh but it works for cells also
so uh I I've explained this part so I'll
just reitray briefly as you adjust
Lambda you swing Bank C from either a
cell type clustering method or uh domain
segmentation method okay so which is
either in one extreme or clustering on
the x-axis and the external clustering
on the y-axis
now uh does the method work now any
algorithm can sound plausible initially
you really have to Benchmark it and we
spend a lot of time Benchmark it on many
many different data types not just one
data type not just one data set
and as you'll see Banksy doesn't have
too many free parameters we didn't have
a lot of room to fiddle
um essentially one free parameter
how do you define neighborhood is it
spatially defined by a radius around the
cell or is it enabled okay sorry
by equilibrium distance in the tissue
space
so uh here's a molefish data set from
the same lab that cow graduated from
Charlie Jones lab
um it's a monetary speech moments data
set last Brain again you can see here
this you know there's one tissue
structure here and a few more here uh
Mouse hypothalamus okay
now uh
if you look at conventional clustering
non-spatial clusting ignore space okay
all these yellow cells all show up in
the same cluster but you can see here
there is there's one structure here one
structure here here the yellow cells are
dense your yellow cells are sparse
Banksy actually separates them out into
two different clusters okay very very
crisply as two different sub types
they're both oligodendrocy they both
mature all the good endocytes but
they're two different subtypes
is that correct right
so here's the first thing we do to make
sense of our results is we look at the
gene expression Matrix so here are some
marker genes of these two cell sometimes
marker genes means genes that have
differential expression in those two
cell types uh this is cell type 1 the
cell type 2 each column is a cell each
row is a marker Gene this is a cell's
own expression this cell's neighbor
expression of the same marker genes you
can see here that in the neighbor
expression space these two cell types
are very crisply separated which kind of
makes sense the cell type composition of
these two neighborhoods is different
right but maybe that's an artifact maybe
the cell's own expression is exactly the
same in which case we'll say Banksy is
making a mistake it's fooled by the
differences in the neighborhood
to assume that the cell itself is
different
right but actually if you look at the
cell itself
you see startly different Expressions
actually you said this color scheme okay
it's statistically it's different but
it's not hugely different okay these
markers and these markers you see a
statistically significant difference in
expression so that means the cell's own
expression is also different in these
two neighborhoods but it's a subtle
difference it's not as strong as this
difference and that's why conventional
clustering that ignores spatial uh
Position will not find the subtle
distinction in these two cell types wait
spatial position you can find it and
that's that's the power of spatialomics
and that's the power of this neighbor
augmentation visually it's so easy to
see right why neighbor augmentation
helps to separate these cell types
and we have many more examples here I'm
just zooming in on this one because if I
remember correctly the same uh
distinction that the other algorithms
could not catch the other spatialomics
clustering algorithms could not catch
this distinction
so uh here's uh same Mouse hypothalamus
uh omics data set another pair of cell
types these are excitatory neurons these
are two different uh sections of this
Mass brain and you can see again
non-spatial Plastering says they're all
the same subtype of excitating neurons
Bank C says that they are two different
subtypes with two different spatial
locations here again neighbor trans
neighbor transform says they are
different cell types own transcriptome
again says there are different cell
types so this this is the validation
okay you always have to eyeball this and
say is it correct or not
so uh beautiful uh is giving you
specially uh is giving a meaningful
results uh I don't have the result here
but we validated all of these by looking
at single cell RNA seek also right you
want some external validation now in
single cell I only see these two
clusters don't separate out cleanly but
if with your conventional clustering
right but if you tell the Single Cell
RNC clustering algorithm only use these
genes now we know with genes look at we
know the feature selection you only use
these genes then these two cell subtypes
do separate out even in single cell are
in async so it is independently possible
to validate this it's just that it's
hard to know that these are the right
genes to Cluster but when we know it
because of the spatial data
so those genes that um
potentially associated with different
subtypes they will not know as far as we
know we just found these two clusters
and then we just did a hypothesis test
with differential expression analysis
between those two clusters and that's
how we've identified a diagnostic
Concepts
differential life technology the English
classes ivg then we look in Singapore
but we didn't know about this genes
before
but I'm sure if we dig deep enough in
the literature someone would have said
something about somebody
another data type slide see so slide
seek is also a spatulomics but you have
beads okay each red circle is a bead as
used to capture uh gene expression uh
came from this spatial region so you can
see here that neighboring cells the
expression can be compounded in one B
okay so it's hard to Cluster uh this
kind of data
uh so again Banksy so this is
non-spatial clustering of this brain
section you can see here that each each
cluster is like slightly messed up okay
in the non-spatial class string so uh
there was a very nice paper uh
presenting this rctd algorithm for
deconvolving these mixed up bead
transcriptomes and then you get a
cleaner representation you get cleaner
Plastering of of each individual cell
type but the cost is you need to know in
advance you need a reference data set of
the transcriptomes of these purified
cell types and you need that independent
X and single cell RNC data only then can
you use this deconvolution method Banksy
does not need deconvolution it just
takes the spatial omics data no external
data and very crisply finds these cell
types because it uses a spatial
information intelligently
and uh and yeah so so that's a big
Advantage just much more convenient
right for the slight C data analysis
uh more examples this and other Mouse
hippocampus brain data set so you can
see here we're comparing Bank C to
non-spatial clustering and various other
uh algorithms for spatial clustering so
these are three other algorithms for
spatial clustering and you can see here
that so the colors indicate the cell
types these cell types are all known
cell types these are not new discoveries
they're known cell types they're kind of
ground truth positive control but the
existing algorithms they cannot clean
the separate separate out these known
cell types in all cases okay so some uh
cell types are merged together here that
actually distinct over here there's a
lot of merging and then over here also
there's over merging uh where you know
there should be it should not be so
dense over here and I think this cell
typo is not cleanly cleanly identified
in this algorithm
uh yeah many more if you look at this is
pre-printism by archive many more such
examples I want to switch gears to
domain segmentation okay where
identifying tissue domains the simplest
thing is find uh okay this has not been
done before spatulomics data but you can
imagine saying a brain organoid right
you have some misdifferentiated regions
uh you have a necrotic core where you're
culturally organoid and the nutrients
are not getting into the core of the
organoid so the cells start dying in the
core of the organoid so these are all
spatially contiguous domains that you
want to segment and then you want to
kick them out so this is a QC step so we
use Banksy for this kind of QC and very
very nicely found these
misdifferentiated zones and also these
uh the necrotic Zone much more cleanly
if you do non-spatial fasting or uh you
know it doesn't work so well markup
random field still works reasonably well
okay but uh this is I think a normal
application of this kind of spatial
Plastering because data QC and uh uh my
collaborator Junior Liu you actually use
this in her work for being organoid more
fish data and then this is the famous
Benchmark data set I mentioned this is a
docile prefrontal politics manually
annotated ground Truth uh within quotes
ground Truth uh layers which algorithm
identifies them most accurately this is
slightly older we have we benchmarked
more algorithms now but the take-home
message is the same bank the y-axis is
the
similarity of the algorithms clustering
to the ground through the manual ground
truth you can see here that Banksy just
has on average the highest similarity to
the manual Grant root of all the
algorithms and the same Banksy algorithm
we just changed Lambda we just increase
Lambda okay
so whereas these are the others are all
algorithms that are specifically
designed for tissue domain segmentation
and it's not obvious why Banksy does
better at first glance because such a
simple method you just smoothing uh it's
just a kernel smoothing of the
neighborhood right I think it's simply
because these other methods either they
make invalid invalid assumption or they
overfit the data it should not be
possible to outdo a simple smoothing
algorithm right so I think there's a lot
more room to for Bank C to grow and
become even better but at least it
avoids some of the pitfalls of the
existing methods
so lastly scalability uh x axis is the
number of cells and we Benchmark Bank
tested Banks here up to 1.5 million
cells you can see here there's the same
runtime as non-spatial clustering the
existing methods some deep learning
Markov random Fields they they simply
crash or fail to return a result very
fast a very small number of cells and
that's not usable on large data sets so
to summarize uh Bank C has a unique uh
biologically motivated Feature Feature
augmentation strategy is the first
algorithm to combine two different
problems together cell type plastic and
tissue domain segmentation and we really
we can apply to many uh cell types sorry
data types and I think other algorithmic
problems also and because perhaps
because it's simple and intuitive and
sense biologically sensible it does
better on all the benchmarks we try
and it finds new cell types actually
which are interesting to explore and
it's very simple very robust orders
magnet attitude faster than other
methods I've thanked vehicle Nigel my
major colleagues was funded by a-star
and also we had a collaboration with
better knob which is one of the
companies in this space thank you
right so thank you very nice talk so
have you tried one of myself
self-communication taking landscape into
account
that's so uh one of my four strokes
wants to do that so yeah
you haven't done it yet so you don't
know whether whether you find different
types of communication for the
populations that are very coherent and
the ones that are mixed up we don't know
yet but it's a very good
idea
yeah thanks a lot for the nice stuff so
this seems very similar to a glass
clustering method so video also kind of
compare it with like yeah I use drug
testing actually yeah so then I think my
question is more on that did you also
find neighbors of Neighbors as an
interesting feature to add in or like
we have not gotten so fancier
so just a question
yeah I was just wondering From biologics
perspective if you say you have
identified novel sense new cell types
from the clustering
um have you done this on some sort of
model organism or so we could easily
genetically manipulate those in actually
biologically confirm this an underlying
biology and it's not just a little bit
of variation
great question I think the first thing
we need to do is try to purify those
cells the subjects and say do they have
any functional difference it's just
functionalizing these things in neutral
weave culture neuronal cells in vitro
they lose their function they lose their
you know in Vivo properties it's very
hard especially when you have such
slightly different subtypes so I think
something in Vivo like what you're
saying maybe genetically perturbed them
is more feasible that would take three
or four years
so think on your question related to the
choice of K the nearest neighbors how
many neighbors we choose is it a three
parameters something you said then how
does it affect uh the results itself uh
I think we it's very robust so we use
somewhere between k equals 30 and k
equals 300 there's almost no difference
I think we just changed
but slender is it's kind of like the
resolution parameter and similar RNC
clustering and for this kind of testing
algorithm you never have done right so
you adjust your parameter and your
eyeball it you look at the markers you
see does it make sense does it not make
sense
but on average what we found by trial
and errors is that Android Source Point
two
um works for Center classroom let me
just keep it at Lambda equals
because when you whenever you have run
through like you know it's one of the
examples
once the proper separation right
right so if you don't know what this is
operation
do you have any suggestions
doing that in the case where you know we
already know
to be honest it's just empiricism for
all the data sets I've shown here after
we analyze them this reading the
literature looking at signals
Etc now we have some sense for the gram
truth it's not bulletproof some sense
and Lambda equals 0.2.3 seems to work
and continuously across the different
data types different data sets and so on
that's all it's still interested I don't
think there's theoretical way to say
that because
and that's why it is a free parameter
exactly yeah so uh that makes complete
sense and so that would be like a more
fancy version
the other thing
segmentation is always an issue in those
fish days essays plastic tools
by Design basically so you have such
contamination to understand
very well
you try to reduce this contamination or
you think that it doesn't
so we've segmented slide sync data and
the same data
that they all have contamination from
the neighboring cells I suspect that
even when you have high resolution data
like Sub sub cellular resolution data
you will you still want to segment and
you will still need this method because
you'll still need information
say your teaching distance and also like
how you define
like performance of your method for just
when you use KNN because I feel like the
spatial distribution of the cell density
will also like heavily affect how it
performs based on it absolutely so for
example there are some very thin layers
there's so many fat layers around there
the elongated layers so all of that so
again all of that is something that you
can talk on but I think a more
sophisticated method would probably
maybe do some em approach to say uh how
many neighbors to choose for this region
of the tissue uh uh communication labels
how many expression neighbors and so on
so I think it's possible to do uh
iterative optimization and localization
but right now it's kind of one size but
slowly and that makes it very fast
from themselves
yeah so this is busy no no not the
segmentation
that string uh so we're not the next
Market
yeah so the museum at least the current
resolution 100 microns which is hard to
identify cell types right it's only
domain segmentation resume HD I think we
can start to look at that but it is
yeah more almost single side like side
seek is almost
okay let me just stick here
[Applause]